From the library of Congress in Washington DC
You know I was just I was up early this morning and wandering around the city and just
being amazed once again about what a beautiful and impressive city it is and
Just hoping that we can all get together and start doing beautiful and impressive things here in terms of our representatives
I'm trying
there's nothing more important to me than then the books that I write for kids young people ETC and
And the reason I write these books
The reason I came here even though I'm going to talk mysteries later on but [I] didn't come for that is
That I think the best way to get kids reading is given them books. They'll love it's kind of common sense
and
I
I don't think it happens
enough in [in] some of the schools
And I don't think it happens enough in a lot of our homes. I have a friend good friend
who
His wife died he wound up racing is the two boys and they really turned out great
But it never occurred to him that it was his [job] to
Go out and and find books for his boys that they would love
I was not a big reader as a kid although. I was a very good student
The school's I went to I guess with [the] wrong books in our hands in my hands anyway
I still don't like silas Marner
I have an 11 year old jack and Jack. It didn't particularly like to read though
He was a good student as well. Jack is is is very bright and creative
He's 11 now at five year oat an illustrated book called death of the butterfly catcher
Butterfly Catcher gets on a plane travel temper [around] the world doesn't catch a butterfly gets on a boat travels
You only half of the world doesn't catch a butterfly
Gets on a train when Jack was five. He loved trains catches the butterfly
Steps off the train gets hit by a train going the other way
death of the Butterfly catcher
butterfly flies away
but as
Smart as he as he as he kind of is he didn't real
Like to read that much so my wife sue and what we did is when he was 8
we went out and found about a dozen books that we thought he would like Percy Jackson and Hatchet and the warrior Series ETC and
We told Jack you don't have to mow [the] lawn
but you do have to read every day for at least half an hour as much as you want to and
the first summer Jack's response was do I have to and
Then we did the same thing the second summer and Jack's response that summer was okay. That's fine
By the third summer Jack were at a dozen books including to kill a mockingbird
when he was 10, and this past summer he read God knows how many books including huckleberry finn and
The secret for us is soo suan eyes. We made it our responsibility
To find books that we knew he was going to love
About a year ago a year and a half ago. I started a website to help
Not to try to teach people or lecture to [Livermore]
Whatever. It was just to help parents and grandparents and school librarians and teachers and kids
To find books that would turn them on
On this site. It's called Read kiddo read calm and on that site
There's nothing but kind of books that are going to turn kids on
That are also fairly well worthwhile they're divided into you know one to six year olds and then
transitional books and then page Turners and then books that are harder, but worth the effort and
I've done a bunch of interviews on the site with Jeff Kinney and Rick Riordan and Julie Andrews
John Jessica, who I just met here. Who's a terrific? I sherman Alexie [carl], hiaasen
And finally I I I'm writing books for kids a lot of a maximum ride is one series
It's about some kids with Wings
but what it's really about is kids taking responsibility for their actions and
And learning to be responsible for one another that's that's what I think it's about
There is a movie coming and and I think the people who are involved with it are
Are really first-rate avI arad is producing an avI produced Spider-Man and x-Men and iron man
[and] he really cares about doing these things well
they have a script from don Payne who was the head writer on the simpsons for eight years and
He's really a funny and good writer. I think the script is great and then Catherine hardwicke who?
Directed Twilight is directing it so it's a really really good group, and I have the highest hopes for the movie
Which of course is very visual because there's a lot of flying in it?
the second series which you may not be as familiar with is called Daniel x and
Daniel has the greatest superpower of all which is he can create with his imagination
so that series is really about using [your] imagination to overcome impossible odds and
girls Like Daniel but but boys Love Daniel and
That's the hardest thing of all I think to write a series
That boys will love obviously Jeff Kenny's done a great job with that with Wimpy Kid
and that's what I tried to do with with Daniel x
My son Jack gave me the highest praise when he said dad you finally got one right?
About daniel x and then because I'm a busy bee in a nut case. I have witch in Wizard coming out in the fall and
Once again this the idea for that I find kind of irresistible which is imagine if you woke up one morning
And all the freedoms you took for granted all the things you really loved music art
Books movies were but she is so good
Because I talk fast man
that's what happens to the brother and sister who are the main characters in witch in Wizard and
Who happened to be a witch in Wizard?
So who has questions, and I don't have answers, but I can fake it
Yes, but I will do it right go ahead. We don't have time. We're too fast for that
Question is am I going to continue the maximum ride series?
Yeah, as I said Jack is 11, and he grows out of his shoes real fast
Oh, I got to keep ya maximum ride will keep going on for a while
I think I know where it ends, but I'm not sure
Yeah
What color is Max's hair?
What color is Matt because it changes what she changes the lies you know she dyes her hair she's kind of a contemporary girl
It's been blonde. It's ben brown. It's been read. I'd say what color do you want it to be?
Yeah
Um what's your favorite maximum ride book? What's my favorite maximum ride book? I you know that's hard for me
I'm always partial to the first one because it's new and it was hard and so I love the angel experiment. I really like Max
The last one and I you know I the next one that I that that I just finished is I think is pretty good
Too, what do you want?
Um who's playing Max in the movie who's Gonna Play [Maxon] movie?
We don't know yet from what I understand and this is in gospel, but I not for Max
But I think nudge might be will Smith's daughter. I think yeah cool
I jumped out that don't take that one to the but I that's the rumor yeah
What is the maximum you like soccer coming out? Yes? Yeah, let me ask you a question
Are you better now, or when you were like five?
You're better when you were five, but that throws that thing out okay? What's your question?
Oh, when is the maximum ride movie coming out when is the Maximum ride movie coming out?
I'm not sure
It's complicated because there are a lot of special effects because they have so far
They haven't been been able to find any kids who actually fly yeah
Matts you can get in trouble down here. You spoke nationally
She's supposed to wear go ahead one spired you to write Maximum ride. What inspired me um
I've always been you know look I want to lift off. You know
I we have these feet of clay and so that's always interested me the notion of flying the notion of being able to rise above
The limitations that we have as human beings. I think that's a piece of it yep
What tips would you get to aspiring writer um?
What it would advise we get to it to aspiring Writers I?
Just keep doing it over and over and over again
when you finish, whatever whether it's a short story or
novel
Don't just sit down and write the next one just keep doing it you'll keep getting better
It's like anything else except for that one guy in soccer
Yeah, can we expect a daniel x movie when do I expected Daniel x movie? I don't know the guy who did
and
The trucks it turn into monsters. Whatever he did the producer
Transformers he's messing around with it. I tard to say with Hollywood because they they sort of make up stuff
Yeah, I'm not sure is the answer yep. What inspired you to become a writer?
What inspired me to become a writer ah?
let's see I
As I said I wasn't a huge writer as a kid a reader as a kid
And I worked my way through college at a mental hospital, and I worked a lot of night shifts
And I had a lot of free time
I started reading like crazy
And then I started scribbling
and I loved it and somebody said you're lucky if you find something you love and
Then it's a miracle if somebody will pay you to do it, so I love doing it. I do it every day
I did it before I came here in the morning, and it's just a trip for me
Yeah, how'd you choose to write about bird people? How did I write about bird people?
How did you choose to write about them instead of a different I?
said part of it was just a fascination with
With flying and actually my family to my sisters have wings and can fly so that got me going on it
football
Um how'd you get the idea of writing Daniel x?
how did I get the idea of writing Daniel x um I guess I just liked [the] idea of
somebody who could solve problems with their imagination that was part of it, then I like the idea of
This kid who's there? And he's hunting aliens on the earth you probably don't know that
They're aliens all over the place, but there are you probably met a few and didn't know it. Yeah
Have you ever thought of anything where?
the Maximum Ride characters and the Daniel
Have interaction have I ever thought of combining two Daniel, Lexington Maximum ride
The trick is Hollywood
When you sell something there they go, oh
If adding anything that shows up at a maximum ride book we own now. So you have to be care
I did the same thing
I initially I do mysteries
And I was going to put the woman to murder club and an [alex] [cross] thing and they said oh if you do that well
On the woman's murder club, so you wind up not being able to do which is kind of crazy. Yeah
What did you think of the maximum ride manga book that came out? What did I [think] of the manga?
I thought it was pretty cool. I thought it was pretty the manga book
I thought they did a nice job without the drawings were very good. I think she's really talented the second one
I think is coming out
Soon do you know I'm not sure?
Yeah, I
[proved] yeah, what's your favorite children's book? What's my favorite children's book?
I
Don't know I use a lot of them. I lay a wrinkle in time
I yeah, there's just times. I like their reardon's that the percy stuff. I like
Wimpy kid I like
Well, I mean to kill a mockingbird is in the children's book but but it I think it's a book at a certain point
Which is which is one of my favorites for I think I read it when I was 12 or 13
Yeah, did you do a lot of research when you were coming up with the burgh kids. I did yes, I did
I wrote an adult novel
initially with with a flying girl and I talked to
Just so many scientists about the possibilities
And they all said that not that
But things like that will happen in our lifetime with because of the advancements in the and what can what can happen with biotech?
Yeah, this side is a this is a better side. I'm telling you manic moves
Yeah
Who's your favorite author when you were kid pardon me who was your favorite author when you were a kid?
Who's my favorite author when I was a kid?
And I don't know I'm if I think of something up, I'll let you know yet. What was your favorite maximum ride book to write?
Well, I like the first one angel experiment and then and then I like max and I like the two that I'm kind of messing
Around with now saying anxious. You're here I
Thought I didn't much older than this
Yeah in the movie. Do you know who's Gonna play re?
Uh no, I re has a big part because obviously
So what no, but I know who's going to play anybody yet, but they were getting close now
Who's your favorite author buried like now is my favorite author that I like now. There are so many
You know on a real serious level that these are older books Gabriel Garcia Marquez
James Joyce, I think is a wonderful wonderful and one of my favorites
And then Michael connelly who's over there? Don't go see him
Now go see him go see
Now he's very good
and
Then at some of the others I mentioned about kids and I'm missing a lot of the kid authors that I
That I like a lot. Yes, sir
Notre dame
What's your favorite character in the books?
Well, you know I love Max
and
You know she's funny, and she's brave and she's conflicted and she's messed up
and she's you know, so I really I really like her fagin is coming on he's a
He's getting a lot more substance as time goes by and he's a good-looking guy
Hollister
Hollister California is open for
You've been warned. What was my inspiration for you've been warned. Oh, you've been warned
I you know. I think to some extent I was working out with you been warned
a little bit of Catholic childhood
Scary stuff about hell things like that
If you're young don't get you're not ready for you even worn yet. She [is] but some of you might not be
He's working anymore ability that the guy that played edward and the guy that played bella are going to be max and fang
Is there any possibility that the characters from Twilight the two main characters will be max and fang I doubt it
I think there's been a little bit of talk about the guy who played Edward being fag
I'm not this isn't my talk I no yes no no
Yes
No, I it's not in our control
Hollywood just does what they do. They don't bury
They and I must say avi the producer has been terrific
he does involve me more than I've been involved in the past but
I have a lot of funny Hollywood stories this isn't the place yeah too much cursing
Crying weeping yeah is Iggy ever going to get his sight back
Is Iggy ever going to get a sight back? Well? He's had flashes now
He's seeing a little bit more which I don't stan but I take his word for it. Yeah
My son Jackson is a huge fan and he's read all your books and a lot of the other popular books out right now I?
Was thinking to call him my son Jack Jackson
But then I go Jackson Patterson sounds like a receiver for the Oakland Raiders or something so I?
Yeah
Uh do you have a recommendation you mentioned your son reading to kill a mockingbird?
When it's appropriate for that next level of reading. I think people need to figure that out for themselves
I mean, you know your kids, and you got to figure out when they're ready and
Jack was he's you know he's systems very sophisticated now. I don't you know Iii think that parents
I think I do to think one thing that's kind of weird with parents are sometimes is they'll do this age appropriate thing
Or great appropriate its age. I think is the issue and you just need to know your kids
But they'll send their kids to any freakin movie and then ago is this age appropriate yeah
Give me a break. Yeah, you know killing gnomes
Thousands of them is as bad as you know somebody dies in a book yeah
Could you tell something about your process when you write like from the very beginning today?
Tell something about the process when I write well, okay, this is important
I think for any kids here and and you hear this all the time in school
And you don't listen and I didn't listen when I was your age II other when they say outline outline
Outline Outline Outline outline outline. It makes everything easier. You'll get better grades
It will go faster. It will go faster
You will write a better piece you will get a better grade outline so the first step in terms of my writing is Outline I?
Will spend a long time. I'll rewrite the outline five six seven times for any of the max books
And then I write a lot of drafts. I don't I never get stuck
I just keep going if I'm not getting a chapter
I just move on and I'll get it the next time around and I and I write a lot of drafts
Confidence, obviously helps say ignatius your back
How long does it take you to write a book?
I want to take me to write a book usually a year, but I'm but I work on a lot at the same time
Yes, sir. What's your favorite genre? What's my favorite Genre?
geography, no I
Don't you know I like I like a lot of kinds of books as I said I like Michael connelly mystery stuff
I like a lot of the why a books. I'm reading it and I
Like occasionally like a love story. I don't I don't I don't think I have a genre
I don't like war stories too much
I don't know why but I don't yeah
I just wanted to thank you because your books between the adult and the children books have served as real connection between
My son, st.. Ignatius in his papa how great they really thank you for for bringing that up and
one of the reasons
One of the reasons that I started writing for younger people although a lot of adults read the books as well is
I
Would come to signings and people would come up and and go you got my kid reading and a lot of times
they'd have tears in her eyes because it's a huge deal for a lot of parents if the kids aren't reading it really is a
It's a big deal and just go back to what I said before, but if you're having a problem
You got to find books that they're going to like and that doesn't mean
You know my kid likes baseball there for a baseball book if it's a baseball book you got to find a good one
It's got to be stuff where they're getting that's why I'm read kiddo read
We're I've tried to make sure that all the books there are good ones, and there's write-ups not not critiques, but right up
So you can tell what the books are about and it will take you about five minutes to decide whether the site is for you
Or not yet. When's the next maximum ride book coming next maximum Ride book. I believe is March
Yeah, could you just take a few minutes to explain?
How you broke into publishing and sold your first manuscript?
Could I take a few minutes to in terms of how I broke into publishing
Okay, interesting for anybody who writes books and wants to write books
I wrote the first novel when I was
25 or 26 at Thomas Barrowman number it got turned down by 31 publishers
It then won an edgar is the best American first first American mystery of the year
So if you get turned down don't worry about it
Because you might have written a good book and they said before go write another one
but the other thing about about turndowns is I
Remember in the beginning you would get back you know 20 or so letters everyone would have a different point of view
so they're all thinking different things and
but don't worry about it and keep writing if you love to do it yep is the witch in Wizard Book and
Going to be part of a series
The ways in which wish it was Adam
Is the witch and Wizard book going to be part of a series? Yes?
I'm already
Two thirds of the way through the second book yeah
Do you base your character is off anyone you know?
as I [said] might the two sisters of mine who have wings the question was do I yeah uh
Mostly no
No
Yeah, so can you tell us anything about the next Maximum Ride book?
Can I tell you anything about the next Maximum Ride book?
Yeah, fang and Max are
really like each other, but they get pulled apart and
Angel has
Said that fang will be the first one to die an angel is never wrong, but we hope she's wrong this time
How's that? Yeah? What impact?
You guys stay up at the mic because I what impact do you expect your books to have one kids?
On kids, uh-huh?
What impact do I hope do [I] [helped] my books will have my kids I?
hope and this is why I did this that obviously I write books that are very popular and
My hope is that
Look [there] million to kitchen in this country who have never read a book they liked that
is a disaster
Because that means that they're not going to read much. I mean if you go through life
You know anything that you don't you don't like broccoli? You don't eat broccoli
You know so if you've had bad experiences with books it's not a good thing
So I'm hoping that my books will give kids good experiences with with books. They will then read other books
And they'll continue to deal for the rest of their lives
And it will be in different levels as I said you know I like Michael connelly I like
Young adult books I like James joyce so my reading love my reading of books is at different levels
And I hope that's what happened to to a lot of kids because of their having experienced some of my books yeah
I
Love all the adult books you're in which one is your favorite?
Out of all the adult books I've written which ones are my favorites. I you know I'm I'm I'm
Happy that I created alex cross as a character
Michael Bennett whose it that's another series. I have I really love him as a character. I don't know that
I have you know I like Susanna's diary for Nicholas. Which was a love story. They really are a lot a honeymoon
I think is a really good mystery. So there I
Don't like season the machete at all
So I it's a mixed bag no
I don't have any favorite favorite I do a season of machetes definitely what I dislike the most yeah um
What's your favorite series that you've written?
Yes, I was just saying
I
There a lot about me in this I can't really pick even in this grouping maximum ride
Daniel axe witch and Wizard, they're all very different
I'm happy with the way they're going
And I I'm actually doing a book now to book series about Middle school, and it's really juicy
I'll tell you yeah, yeah, I noticed that such as you know. What goes on there now
The world is going to know yeah some of your adult novels you have cold Riders or partners
Yeah, why do you want to be a co-writer? Maybe sure why not? How do you choose are they really you ready the
We're gonna alternate words. Why?
Are you just trying to help other riders? Are they really helping you or what's that? Oh, I I got it
I got into the co-writing thing by accident a friend of mine writes a lot articles for the New York times and we were out
Golfing one day, and we sat down
Afterwards and then we were talking and I de scoffs to and I started talking about it
And I said let's try to write it together. It was really a lot of fun and
What I won, I could never write all the stories. I have in my head
I just thought wouldn't have the time to do it and I find with the co-writers that
and you know almost all television shows not all you know I written like teams a lot of movies are and
You wind up getting a nice mix of talents, and you know my strength is storytelling?
my weakness is the patients with with craft, so
You know I'm not the greatest stylist in the world. I could be better if I if I wrote one book a year
So it's a nice mix for me all right. [thank] you. Yeah
How do you feel about being included in the poker game on castle?
How did I feel about being in a poker game and castle? It was great. It was a lot of fun
I thought it came off nicely. They did a nice job. They cut nice pieces of me in there
This is a TV show that I was in but inviting me back
But I say, it's just too hard for me to go all the way out
It's three days and you know so I didn't go back, but I really enjoyed it
And I think it's a good show
It's a good writer that put it together yep, what is the ambience of when you write your surrounding?
What's the ambience of when I right?
There's angels
and fly um I
Aren't all over the place now. I i have been all well
I'll tell you what I mean my office, it's it's sort of big it looks out on the water
And I have a table that goes not a table
but a shelf that goes all the way around their bookshelves on top and a shelter goes all the way around the room and
It's filled with manuscripts things that I'm working on outlines and right now. They're 27 so it's in Madhouse
I said I was a nutcase earlier, and I'm not kidding
Yeah, it's Casanova coming back, and we'll cross captures Captain over coming back, and we'll cross catch him I
Didn't he die?
Didn't I I don't know yeah? Do you know I would have you seen him
I yeah, I thought he was dead, but maybe not okay. I will say maybe
Yeah, how many books have you wrote? [I] don't know how many books have I written?
60 maybe how many of you written?
nine yet one is for A
Few pages all right, okay?
Well that's how it starts if you write a page a day at the end of the year you'll have a book
Yeah, so how did you feel when you looked at the check for movie rights for your book?
How do I feel when I look at the checks?
for the movie rights to my book
You know it's still one. It's fun
To it remains kind of unreal to me, and that's probably why it's fun
We have a choice more [parts] unreal, huh? We love that. You're getting rewarded. Yeah that way title I
It was always fun. It was fun when I wasn't making anything it was fun when I wasn't fun to be turned down initially
But it was it's always been fun to write the books
Are we good?
Anybody else we're good. Thank you
This has been a presentation of the library of congress visit us at loc.gov